foreign
quitting which is the new Modern Trend
where employees essentially stop trying
but they remain on the job attempting to
Sail by on minimal effort doing the bare
minimum this was a movement pioneered by
gen Z with a big assist from Millennials
who are always eager to join any Trend
especially one that involves being lazy
of course I say the movement was
pioneered by gen Z but they in fact did
not invent laziness though they are the
only generation maybe narcissistic
enough to think that they did no they
invented the phrase and the hashtag and
The Tick Tock video is promoting it and
now the makers of quiet quitting are
back with a new hit called hashtag act
your wage this is another viral Trend
which is essentially the same thing as
quiet quitting sort of taking the Marvel
approach where the sequel is a carbon
copy of the original the ACT your wage
Trend which has taken off on Tick Tock
is apparently best explained by this
viral video which has millions of views
from Tick Tock user Sarai Marie let's uh
take a look
Veronica I'm going to have you take this
home and work on it tonight okay
respectfully Susan I'd rather spend time
with my family
Veronica did you just decline the zoom
meeting that's at 6 30 tonight
oh yeah I did I did do that yeah because
it's outside of my working hours nine to
five so I won't be attending
all right Veronica I do need you to be
available during your vacation okay
Susan you'll be blocked on my vacation
because I won't be answering
okay Veronica I'm gonna need you to
complete all this today
Susan do I look like two people to you
no oh okay just making sure because that
looks like the work of two people right
right and I'm one I'm just one person
right
and it's time to go home five o'clock
hey thank you bye
it would appear that um
acting your wage means being so grating
and annoying and shrilled that you end
up sitting alone in an empty corner of
the office because everybody else has
jumped out the window now if you're
still confused about what this movement
is supposed to be the New York Post has
more details quote the video is tagged
act your wage a hashtag that has a mass
37.6 million views and counting on Tick
Tock it's part of a movement among young
workers to only do what they're paid for
and no more and to urge their co-workers
to do the same proponents of act your
wage see it as setting a firm healthy
boundary in the workplace acting your
wage might sound similar to quiet
quitting which became the biggest
buzzword in the office as the summer
games event but there's a fine line
between the two movements well
motivation is the bridge between the two
but there's still two very different in
separate constructs Maisha and Martin
head of people analytics of the software
company work human told the post in
short quiet quitters are doing the bare
minimum and trying to get away with it
while the ACT your Wagers are doing
exactly what they're paid to do not more
and not less
so I mean they're all just a bunch of
lazy bastards in other words for a real
world example of this phenomenon um not
that anyone needs a real word example of
laziness I think we all kind of get it
but Insider has an article about acting
your wage and it tells the story of a 22
year old cashier named Claire
and this is kind of important for a
point we're going to make here this is
what it says Claire is adamant about
acting your wage she has watched
psychological the store being fully
staffed where workers feel they can have
a life outside the job and then
something happens to upset the balance
whether it's management changing workers
hours or a particularly demanding
customer and co-worker after co-worker
walks out quote if the job is something
I can do and it's not taking from my
life more than it gives I.E the money
then I can withstand fussy customers and
strange management I can brush all that
off she said I do understand there are
times when a job is just not worth it
though for Claire who makes about 13 an
hour in Texas the job is still worth it
but that's because she acts her wage she
does what she's expected to do but
doesn't take on more or stretch herself
more than she needs to it's another side
of quiet quitting and it's a practice
that she thinks is especially important
for Gen Z
quote I have control over when I show up
and when I leave she said while I'm
there I'm going to try at least to do as
I'm told but I'm not going to do a nine
to nine for Claire acting her wage is
all about keeping her identity separate
from work and not feeling the need to go
above and beyond
yes don't go above and beyond that is
indeed the Timeless Mantra of losers and
mediocre nobodies everywhere
now we should first note here as we did
with the Quiet quitting trend
the proponents of this approach do in
theory make a couple of valid points so
it's true that you should have a life
outside of work
it's also true that you need to know how
to set boundaries not just at work but
in general so you don't get taken
advantage of but both of these potential
positives are ultimately neutralized
because for one thing
there is no real value in ensuring that
you have extra time outside of work if
you aren't going to spend that extra
time doing something enriching and
worthwhile
so most of these people will just go
home and scroll through Tick Tock that's
how they're spending that extra time we
heard in the video that Veronica
wanted to spend more time with her
family but the problem is that these
days most people in their 20s don't have
families so by family they really mean
their couch their phone and their HBO
Max subscription
and and if you have to choose between
putting some extra hours in at work
and staring like a zombie at a glowing
screen for six hours until you fall into
a drooling stupor and eventually Drift
Off to Sleep
I think the former is often a better
choice
second setting boundaries is important
but in the adult world you need to know
how to do that with a certain amount of
tact and diplomacy
so the real trick is to be firm and
clear and yet not obnoxious
well the problem in the end of the video
uh what the video is recommending is
that employees act like a bunch of
spoiled toddlers turning up the smarmy
level to 100 screeching like overgrown
bats and acting uh offended their boss
would even ask them to do a little bit
extra
let's see you can't that's what you have
to understand kids you cannot talk to
your boss that way you might you might
wish that you could but you can't
so in the real world or your boss comes
up to you no I'm not doing that Susan
get the hell out of here this is not a
movie you can't talk to people that way
this this might be how you your parents
may allow you to talk to them that way
and that's why and that's why you never
learn the lesson
but in reality you can't it's a good way
to get yourself fired in the real world
if you're only going to do the bare
minimum and on top of that you're also
unpleasant disrespectful and irritating
there's no reason for your employer to
keep you around any longer than it takes
to find some other warm body to sit in
your chair
you have to always ask yourself that
question I know we don't want to ask
ourselves this question because it's a
difficult question yes but but you know
at your job or whatever you're doing
it's like you have to ask yourself
um what what role am I really serving am
I even needed
and if you if you've made yourself
Expendable that's going to be a problem
for you
and making yourself Expendable it's
certainly one way to approach life the
other way to approach it is to strive to
be indispensable invaluable
undeniable
but that takes effort and it takes
Talent
and here's an important point it takes
time
so it's quite notable that gen Z they're
pushing you know these Trends
um apparently deciding that working hard
going above and beyond running the extra
mile Etc is not worth the strain the
cost benefit calculation doesn't work
out in their favor they say
Claire you know the cashier she's a ride
to this conclusion and yet Claire is is
22 years old
at the upper generational range the
oldest members of gen Z would be like 25
or 26.
how could you possibly have determined
already in your mid-20s after having
been in the Working World for a few
years at most
that there's no point in putting an
extra effort
I mean you've decided already that the
whole thing's a suckers game
what did you work one overtime shift and
then decide that ambition is pointless
what did you expect
did you think you put in five extra
hours behind the cash register at the
grocery store and the next day they'd
make you CEO of Krogers
well I spent one entire whole day trying
hard and I haven't become a millionaire
yet so I give up
that's not the way the Life Works
not everything follows the rules of
instant gratification
you can't always get results in 60
seconds or less
the whole world is not a microwave it
doesn't work that way success comes
slowly and painfully and with lots of
Peaks and valleys valleys and
frustrations and with stops and starts
and with hardship
now speaking personally
I am now at a point in my career where
I'm willing to say that I am having some
success I'm not done not nearly I'm not
satisfied not even close but I've hit
certain Milestones that are important to
me that I've been working towards and uh
and so you know and that's a good thing
do you know how long that took
like a decade and a half more than that
actually
and you're given up after what three
months
you're ready to quiet quit when you're
just quiet started last week how fast do
you think success comes
we said hard work pays off we never said
it pays off in 30 seconds
life is not an ATM you can't just press
a button and the cash comes out it takes
longer a lot longer to get the payout
but here's the good news
if you're a younger person
and you're just starting out in your
career
the deck has been cleared okay many of
your peers are are settling for
mediocrity already they haven't even
tried yet
and they've decided there's no point in
trying
they they totaled their cars on the
first speed bump they came across they
ran into a mild Breeze and were knocked
on their asses and have no interest in
getting up
this is an opportunity for you
if you're not one of those people
as long as you have slightly more
fortitude and a slightly better work
ethic
than all those other losers you have an
opportunity
you you only need to be slightly more
useful than a slug to set yourself apart
and then imagine if you went above and
beyond even that
imagine if you really tried
the stage is set for you to succeed
while your competition makes Tick Tock
videos explaining why they aren't even
trying
let them be satisfied with a lackluster
life filled with indifference and
excuses
you show up early you take the overtime
you take on the extra projects you look
to make your job more challenging not
easier
let them be cynical about it and scoff
about what are you even trying for
let them do it because you're climbing
the ladder while they're all crowding
around the Bottom Rung
hoping someone pays off the rest of
their student loans
one day you'll be the boss
and you can gather together all of these
low effort lumps on a log and tell them
all at once
as I tell them now
you're all canceled and that'll do it
for today
for this portion of the show anyway as
we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]